I'm fine
would you look
we'll get somebody to clean that up
we're the ones I gotta clean that up
damn it Michael
we have to have this thing serviced
Val I need the space
all right guys clear out everybody out
promise me you're gonna clean up I can't
promise what I'm gonna do or not do
promise me that obviously I'm gonna
clean up stress is like the uptight
mayor of a town who's saying hey we're
uptight you can't dance and then you
have to be like oh yeah mayor stress
well watch this and then
we dance
oh how we dance
[Music]
sex also works
cold front coming into the warehouse oh
better put on your ski boots wow
happy New Year Daryl hey Daryl
you ever done this
okay 300 boxes of 20 pound White
that's 75 boxes per person so that's not
so bad negative 300 boxes for me zero
for you Chumps deal with it
[Music]
yep
I have already put down the deposit do
you understand how a deposit Works Mike
I'm not having fire eaters in a paper
warehouse It's casino night like Las
Vegas or fire eaters all over the place
except my warehouse well actually it's
my warehouse I'm just gonna put this
over there
this is not a good idea right here
okay
Message in a Bottle The Postman yeah
so
I found this grease and then I
remembered that you thought it was a
great idea you did say it was a great
idea I heard you say it
so it's not the dumbest idea it's not
the greatest one the fact remains we got
to move these boxes and it's clear we're
not going to carry them
so sadly it's the best idea exactly I
think we're ready to give this
yeah is he okay he'll be fine thank you
to our hosts
hey Michael
this ain't over
huh what is going on oh hey guys why is
the forklift in the wall why is the
truck empty uh it's not totally empty is
that grease on my floor
okay
I can see why you're angry you're coming
into this cold but believe me a lot of
thought went into this and did your
brains tell you to ruin these boxes with
grease okay Daryl listen and then you
will understand
the boxes were ruined during our first
trial testing so now it's cool because
we found another use for them okay all
right that's look all we were trying to
do is we thought we could come up with a
more efficient way to do things and and
we did I don't know Jim tell them what
it's called
that's all right no Jim tell him what a
name is doesn't matter what the name is
senior lodenstein that's stupid see nor
loganstein tell them why it's called
that gym that's okay we're good now Jim
tell us why it's called senor lodenstein
porquez we Rapido okay you know what
it's been a real busy day what do you
say we put all this away let me see it
it's uh it's in beta testing let me see
it get the thing
Trace ah
yeah I lost my client
okay Jimmy this is for you to show you
that anything is possible fantastic
right yep it's also for the troops
Doctor Is In
oh
this is the forklift you need you need a
license to operate this machine that
means the upstairs office workers can't
drive it quiz Mike should you drive the
forklift I can and I have no no no no no
no I said should you you should not
drive it you should not drive the
forklift you're not allowed to drive the
forklift it's not safe you don't have a
license guys I'm not the only one who's
driven the forklift Pudge has driven the
forklift Matt
I thought your name was Pudge no it's
it's always been managed okay
um her her yes her is qualified to work
a dangerous machine you are not
okay all right fine do you understand
that yes we do safety training every
year or after an accident
we've never made it a full year
this particular time I was reaching for
a supply box on the top shelf
when one office worker who shall remain
nameless
kicked the letter from under me and
yelled hey Daryl how's it hanging
and I fell and busted my ankle
I'm legitimately scared for my workers
the baler can flatten
crush your entire body without skipping
the beats
how many people a year do you think get
their arms cut off in a baler Baylor I
hardly know her damn it Michael pay
attention man anybody want to take a
guess five bucks says it's over 50. you
really want to bet anybody ever since
March Madness ended I am so bored I'm in
it okay you're on 10 people Michael
10 people would you like to be one of
them
these are very dangerous machines down
here and the upstairs workers Michael
should not go anywhere near them yes yes
but it wouldn't be the worst thing in
the world it would be the worst thing in
the world
it's a big red trash
I got it I got it
only on the rarest of occasions
there is no occasion gonna go near this
stuff okay